hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
leveraging acoustic and tip-based liquid
handling to increase
sars-kobi-2 sequencing throughput i am
jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann coulter life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
eric chow
assistant professor university of
california san francisco
dr chao you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today again my name is eric chow and i'm
with the center for advanced technology
in the biochemistry and biophysics
department
at the university of california san
francisco and today i'm going to talk to
you about work that we've done to
leverage acoustic
and tip based liquid handling to
increase our stars kobe 2
sequencing throughput first slide is
just a
quick disclaimer you can take a look at
this
and again the focus of today's talk is
on coveted sequencing
and the role it plays in covet genomic
surveillance and how we
can scale this up just because there's
an important need on the left hand side
is a graph just showing you the number
of cases that have been
um you know present in the united
kingdom uh one of the countries with the
kind of best coveted surveillance
efforts going on and you can see that
while there's a huge increase
at the beginning of the year there's a
rapid drop and things were looking
pretty good
until recent weeks where you're starting
to see a spike
in infections and a lot of this is
really driven by
the appearance of this delta variant
first identified in
india and you can see this on the panel
on the right hand side
where you can take a look at the
fraction of cases that are made up of
different strains so initially the alpha
variant in blue made up most of the
infections
in the uk but you can see just a few
months ago the delta variant in yellow
started to show up in the sound making
a uh the majority of the uh the cases um
that are coming up and being detected
and again it's thought that
the delta variant may be 50 more
effective
than the alpha variant which was again
itself 50
more effective uh than the original
strain and so this demonstrates the
importance of being able to do genomic
surveillance to see what type of strains
are circulating out there
and which ones may be increasing
frequency which may be an indicator
of uh increased transmissibility
so it's estimated that to do the minimum
amount of sequencing required
to perform genomic surveillance is five
percent of positive samples need to be
sequenced to be able to track these
variants
if you can sequence a higher amount uh
greater than five percent you'd be able
to detect
new variants that are spreading uh
faster and earlier
it's also important to sequence positive
samples from vaccinated individuals to
identify potential variants
that could escape the vaccine just a
quick note you know all the major
vaccines in use are still very effective
against all identified variants but
there's always a worry that a variant
may come about that can escape
vaccine protection and genomic
surveillance is going to be
important to identify those potential
variants
so worldwide surveillance is going to
require tens of thousands of samples per
day
if you assume that you just want to
sequence five percent of all cases so
this works out to about 20 000 samples
per day again this is really the the
minimum that you would want to sequence
ideally you'd be able to sequence a
greater fraction of cases
and be able to identify variants that
are arising sooner
again there's also a need to sample it
to sequence additional samples
uh from infections of individuals who've
been vaccinated to
identify potential escape variants and
we need a mix of both really high
throughput centralized sequencing
centers and lower throughput
decentralized methods
um to be able to cover um all the
different areas that require genomic
surveillance
there are currently several main methods
of sars kobe 2 sequencing there are many
many vessels
being developed all the time but i'm
just listing probably the three major
ones
that are being used originally
metagenomic next generation sequencing
was the first one
that was used essentially this just
takes a sample and sequences
everything in there and asks what's uh
what's present
and so um this was a method that had
been used to sequence and identify
different types of pathogens present and
until
sarge kobe 2 specific methods came about
this was the main method people were
using the sequence
uh sequencing samples there are some
challenges and that it's not quite as
sensitive for high ct samples or low
tide or samples
it can also be expensive and uh somewhat
laborious
uh what came out more recently was
something from the uh the arctic network
a group of labs that have published
a lot of great and amazing protocols uh
not just for stars kobe 2 but for a lot
of other pathogens
in the previous few years and with their
scheme they
actually use a multiplex pcr reaction to
amplify
different amplicons that tile the entire
pathogen
so what they typically do is split the
amplicons into
the even and odd numbers and then all
the uh
even number amplicons are in one pool
all the odd number amplicons are another
pool
after you do this amplification it goes
into a traditional library preparation
dad adapters and barcodes
and then you can put this onto a
sequencer and this usually takes a bit
more time
in preparation mainly due to the length
of time
for the multiplex pcr reaction
and can also be a little laborious as
well just because of the damson library
prep
a new method that came out uh probably
about uh uh last summer uh
when the preprint came out was the
tailed arctic method
and so this is very similar to the
arctic method but instead of using
standard primers for the multiplex pcr
they added adapter tails onto the end
of the primers and this allows you to
essentially perform your library prep
with two sequential pcrs the first pcr
will amplify your stars kobe 2 targets
and introduce
alumina read one or re-two tails or for
other sequencers and then
the second pcr that's performed will
finish the library prep process adding
in the rest of the adapters
as well as indexing barcodes so you can
pull samples together
the one downside of this method while
it's fast and
a lot easier on the preparation time it
required a longer sequencing
method so paired in 250 sequencing on
lumina platforms
which takes a bit more time than the
traditional paradigm 150 sequencing
that's been used
and it also requires four separate
multiplex pcrs
um to amplify the stars kobe 2 uh genome
and i'll talk about that
in a couple slides um but
due to speed and cost most groups are
currently using one of the arctic
methods now
and again both of them have uh
limitations
and um so what we really want in a dl
method something that's really high
throughput
has rapid turnaround time uh reduced tip
usage as i think
most people on this uh this seminar
today
uh realized that uh there are supply
chain issues with with tips
uh and ideally it's deployable on all
luminesce sequencers which
means that the method has to be able to
run on paradigm 150 sequencing the
paired in 250 sequencing
used in the current tailed arctic method
requires paired in 250 sequencing which
is restricted to the my seek
and the low throughput nova seat kits
ideally the method is going to be low
cost as well
and so in our minds the the you know
ideal method would be based on the
tailed arctic method just because the
workflow is really simple and really
high throughput
um but would only require paradigm 150
sequencing
and i'm going to talk a little bit more
about the kind of development of the
detailed arctic method and this has been
a really great method to really
increase uh throughput just because
sample preparation
uh was really a big bottleneck and so on
the top panel
in blue what i'm showing you is a uh
list of
amplicon coverage of the original arctic
method that does multiplex
amplification in two pools and then
sample prep
afterwards and you can see it's you know
relatively even coverage
uh across the amplicons you do have some
dropouts in the first
version of the tailed arctic method they
used two different pools
and the handles that they attached onto
their primers are nextera reed one re2
primer handles and you can see the
coverage looked a little bit more uh
uneven you can see it's a bit spikier
compared to the standard arctic method
and so what the authors did was they
instead of using two pools they split
the amplicons into four pools
uh and were able to get a bit more even
coverage so the downside of this is that
instead of two multiplex pcrs per sample
you have to do four multiplex vcrs per
sample
and then combine and pull them and so
in the uh cat what we decided to do was
um
tried doing one thing first thing is
that we realize that the next terra
tales are very long
and exterior primers also have 19 bases
homology in the underlying section
between the read 1 and read 2 sequences
and so we
realized this could probably cause
problems with the multiplex pcr
and so what we decided to do was swap
these out for trueseek read one
and read two tails uh that were
shortened uh so they're only 17 and 18
bases in length versus 33 and
and the region of homology between uh
the read one re2 primers
is quite a bit shorter uh for truseek
compared to nyx tara
and to rapidly prototype these we
actually ordered o pools from idt so we
didn't have to order a large set
of individual oligos we could order a
small set
and have a relatively quick turnaround
time to begin testing
this process and so
results on the bottom is just from one
kind of representative sample
um that we were able to get fairly even
coverage and this was with only
two pools uh instead of four multiplex
pcr pools for uh for each sample
and so we see characters that dropouts
or lower coverage
in these areas that are seen with the
traditional arctic method
and so this looked relatively good so we
decided to move forward with
384 samples that had been processed
using the traditional arctic method
and what i'm showing you here is our
results so this is
a a plot of average viral ct
versus percent of the genome called and
for our work we've been using a 92
cutoff of genome coverage to um
delineate passing versus failed samples
and so the passing samples are in blue
and the failed samples that didn't hit
that 92 coverage are in orange
and so you can see that there's
definitely a strong ct
dependence here and so we got about 72
percent of samples um
passing which is a little bit lower than
the
standard arctic method that these
samples run on as well
and so our summary of this method was
that um you know the tail 400 based uh
method
uh using these trueseek tails um seemed
to work
um we would like to have uh kind of
improved uh um
uh sample passing rates uh but there's
still a downside in that it took
uh it required paired into the
sequencing which requires about two days
um on the uh the novaseq sb flowcell
so at the time we were working on this
uh newtail method
uh we saw that josh quix group also had
a 275 base pair arctic primer set
that showed even more even coverage than
the 400 base pair set
but with their protocol they went
through the traditional library prep
after the multiplex pcr and so we
decided to do
since our trueseek tailed versions uh
seem to work better than the xterra
tailed versions we
ordered a uh again an opal uh using a
tailed version of these 275 base pair
primers
with our truseq sequences and uh we
ordered these in
two two modes first was this is opal so
that we can begin testing um as soon as
possible because the faster around time
and we also ordered each of the primers
individually uh
in plates um just so that we could scale
up uh to about a hundred thousand
reactions
um total we didn't want to have to
revalidate primers um
you know several times so we did put in
a big order with idt
and these can actually be delivered into
echo plates which is an acoustic liquid
handler i'll tell you in a moment
and there are certain advantages to
ordering in an echo plate namely
you can create pools almost on the fly
and change your ratios
of different primers which can be
important to normalize
uh coverage with these multiplex pcrs
and so um the tail 275 base method
actually gave more even coverage than
the tailed um
400 base method uh which was also seen
in in joshua's group
using the standard arctic procedures of
library prep
comparing the 475 base protocol so these
are two samples
top one uh was run using the tail 400
base pair protocol
i showed earlier and the bottom is the
tail 275
base pair method that
that we worked on and so this looked
really promising so we ran a couple more
samples
just to do some comparisons that were
run using the standard arctic method
of uh of you know multiplexing
amplification and then
library prep versus our tailed 400 base
pair
prep versus the tail 275 base prep
and you can see that while the standard
arctic performed better than our tailed
400 base method the tailed 275 base
method
actually worked a lot better for these
representative samples
and that most of them gave greater than
92 percent
coverage of the sars cov2 genome and
again this is depicted
uh in these these green boxes the one
sample that didn't uh
didn't pass um actually had some
evaporation issues
uh with the plate so we're not sure if
this is a true failure or not
um but it looked really promising we
decided to move forward
with this this method and so
to really increase throughput we wanted
to really automate this method
to be able to sequence as many samples
as as possible in a high-throughput
manner
and so that really requires the use of
automation and there are several
advantages to automation besides
increased throughput
these include increased reproducibility
prevents user errors that can mix up
samples and also preserve staff sanity
you can imagine trying to work in 96 or
34 well plates with multi-channel
pipe headers and it's just going to be a
huge headache
and a lot of opportunities for for
mistakes the other thing we wanted to do
was perform our reactions in 384
well format again for for high
throughput
production and so this requires the need
to move samples from
96 to 3d forward format we also want to
minimize tip usage to the supply chain
issues and lastly we want to make sure
that we minimize contamination so
a lot of people on this call may have
worked in you know just other genomics
projects in the past but when you're
dealing with pathogen sequencing it's
and and starts cov2 sequencing it's very
different from other
standard mgs experiments where you might
be working with blood samples or rna-seq
input samples and for a lot of those
samples you probably have relatively
equal
inputs across all your samples so if you
have a little bit of cross-contamination
between samples
it's just something you don't see uh
routinely it's difficult to uh to
detect but with stars kobe 2 um
samples that are positive can vary in
cts by up to 30 cycles
as what we've seen and so this
represents about a billion-fold
difference
in abundance from the most concentrated
sample to the least concentrated sample
and so you have to be very very careful
about contamination
and we feel that using some of the
steps with the acoustic lipid handler we
actually minimize
chances of contamination i'll talk about
that in a couple of slides
so in this next slide is the automation
workflow that we developed using various
liquid handlers and so i'm going to walk
you through this process and also gives
an overview of the protocol itself
as well and there'll be links to the
detailed protocol in the resources
section of this webinar
that you can access after this call so
first we start off with rna
and so this can either be in 384 plates
or 96 weld plates in our case
um our samples are in in 96 well plates
so we have a biomec
fx with a 96 wall head and eight channel
uh
span head that we use to essentially
consolidate
496 well plates into a single 384 well
plate
with our reverse transfix uh reverse
trans um
transcription master mix and this is
actually done
in a echo acoustic low dead volume
source plates and i'll talk about that
in the next few slides and so earth
transcription occurs
in this echo source plate and once
that's done the source plate goes into
the echo 525 acoustic liquid handler and
this system uses sound to transfer small
volumes 25 nanometer droplets of liquid
uh from a source plate into a
destination plate and our destination
plates
here are our two 275 base
tailed multiplex pcr plates so in one
plate we have all the odd amplicons
and one other plate we have all the even
amplicons and so we transfer one mic
leader
of the cdna product into each of these
plates
these are then thermocycle to amplify up
the stars cov2 targets
and then we use a bimec i7 with a 384
wheel head and a span8 head
to combine and dilute the amplified cdna
products and to stamp this
into an indexing pcr plate after this
indexing pcr plate is thermocycled
it then is transferred using the biomec
i7
into a another echo
low dead volume plate and we use the
echo
to pull an equal volume of each sample
we pull 500 nano liters of each sample
into a new destination plate and then
combine that into a single tube
where we do a single bead based cleanup
so after the speed based cleanup
uh the samples are quantified in qc'd
and go on to the sequencer
and so just want to note that in this
process we're actually only using
two tips total for this procedure the
first tip is used to transfer rna
for the 96 well plate into the low dead
volume plate
and the second tip is used to combine
the amplicons
dilute them and spot them into the
indexing pcr and the same box of tips
is then used to transfer the amplified
barcoded samples
into the echo ldd plate for transfer
and minimizing this tip uses really
helped with our our throughput as well
and we haven't had any issues with with
tip supplies
so in this next slide i just wanted to
briefly go over how the echo acoustic
liquid handler works because a lot of
people may not be familiar with it it's
a
essentially a random access liquid
handler that
transfers liquids using sound and so the
way this works is you have a
source plate uh that's an acoustic
qualified plate
and there are a couple different formats
in 3d for well format
and also a six wool reservoir for the
echo 525
that we're using there are also higher
and systems to transfer smaller volumes
they can use 15 36 well source plates
but for us the echo 5g5 works very well
it's kind of
it's a nice volume regime so this source
weight will go into the echo
and then next you put on your
destination plate
in our case we've been using these
384-wheel pcr plates this is put on the
um this little uh platform the platform
will grab
and grip the plate and then it'll flip
and rotate 180 degrees so that this
plate now faces
down the source plate will retract into
the instrument and in the instrument the
source plates down on the bottom and the
destination plate
that's upside down facing it are in
really close proximity
and below the source plate is a
transducer that will send pings of sound
energy
uh into the source well and this causes
really tiny 25 nanometer droplets to
get ejected from the meniscus straight
up and because the source plate and
destination plates are so close
facing each other uh there's very little
chance of cross-contamination happening
because a 25 nanometer droplet
essentially flies
straight up exits the source well and
enters the destination well
and so the system is really quick it can
transfer several hundred droplets
per second so copying a three or four
well plate
um and stamping out one mic leader only
takes a few minutes and again doesn't
use
any tips we've had some questions about
how we
um perform our reverse transcription
incubation in the echo load dead volume
plate and so
optimally you would have a flat block
thermocycler but there aren't many of
those
around typically in labs and so what we
did was we used a
bi-rad c-1000 384 wall thermocycler that
we had
and we essentially modified it by buying
some some things off of amazon
essentially because it was the fastest
way to get supplies
and so first thing we did was we took a
thin thermal pad
and so this is a relatively soft
conductive
thermally conductive pad that we cut to
size to put on
top of the 3d four wall thermocycler and
then on top of that we put a thin
aluminum shim stock on top to give it a
nice flat surface
and this is how we modified our c1000
thermocycler and then we put an echo ldv
plate on top that's a little hard to see
in the right hand side but it's um a
clear plate that's now sitting on top of
the shim
that's sitting on top of the thermal pad
so thermal pad will help with
with heat transfer and the shim provides
a nice flat surface
for the echo ldb plate to uh to sit on
top of
and we compared both a we compared both
running rt reactions in pcr plates as
well as the echo ldv plates and
we didn't see any changes in performance
and again the benefit here
is using one less piece of labware and
less tips that are required to do your
downstream transfer
and so in the uh
and in this next slide um uh what i'm
showing you on the left hand side is the
results i showed earlier from our tail
400 base method and on the right hand
side are those same samples that have
been run using our tail 275 base method
and so if you recall with the tail four
into base method we only had a
72 success rate but with the tailed um
275 method uh we actually had a 90
percent success rate again this is
dictated by a number of samples that
have greater than 92 percent
uh coverage of the star scope huge
genome and when we actually look at
samples
below ctf 30 our success rate is
actually 97.3
with this test set and down the bottom
is a little chart where we kind of broke
down
um the the samples according to ct bins
and you can see at the lower cts you
were getting very high
recovery of samples
and it's really once you get to cts
above 30
that the success rate starts to uh to
drop a bit
but we've been very happy with with this
protocol
and then using it to run a lot more
samples and so with the the current
status is
uh we're currently running 768 samples
um twice a week so our batches are two
three four well plates of samples at a
time
and we've been seeing above a 95 uh
success rate
uh again uh determined by more than 92
coverage
and so um our biggest limitation right
now is actually not in
our liquid handling but it's more in in
staff time so the staff
have to perform other duties as well and
so
they can only handle so many runs you
know per week
because of their their other duties but
the liquid handlers
buy our calculations if you had enough
staff you could easily process
eight three hundred eighty four plates
of samples uh per day
um we have pretty rapid turnaround time
with this method the um
384 768 samples can be
prepped and ready for sequencing in
about eight hours so it's about one
shift or one workday and again
really importantly we have reduced tip
usage we started off with three tips per
sample but realized we could actually
get that down to two tips per sample
and the method is a fairly low cost that
uses off-the-shelf reagents
and because we're working in 3d pro well
format uh we're working with 10
microliter reactions and so we have one
rt reaction
and three pcr reactions to the two
multiplex reactions
and one indexing pcr reaction um and
again
because we have the the echo it makes
pooling samples really easy
which means that we can pool or amplify
samples before cleanup
and do a single bead-based cleanup on a
combination of all 384 samples and so
a lot of this has been really enabled by
combining
the the unique aspects of our our
various
beckman liquid handlers a big one is the
echo 5g5 that allows
us to pull samples really quickly it
also allows us to transfer small volumes
with good accuracy as well as minimizing
contamination
and then uh we have been able to use our
biomec i7
and fx's to handle our 96 and 384 well
transfers
um sometimes i get the question that if
i was going to start over
um how would i set this up and if that
was the case i would probably just start
off with the
echo 525 and then a single biomic i7
with a dual arm that can be configured
with both a 3d pro wheel head and a 96
wall head because that would handle
all of our kind of liquid handling needs
uh so instead of having three
instruments we could actually make do
with
uh with two instruments all right so
um you know this has been been great and
so
um i've been thinking about some other
ways of increasing throughput mainly how
do you deal with
um maybe the uh um being shorthanded in
terms of staff time and how to really
leverage the
amount of capacity on the the automation
platforms and so one piece of automation
that i have
in another lab that's not not the cat is
a lapse a beckman access system and so
this has an echo 525 liquid handler
attached to it
as well as an access robotic arm that
can
feed many plates up to 80 or 100 plates
depending on your configuration
stacked in hotels the system also has an
automated
sealer and peeler and a plate centrifuge
as well as
a bulk dispenser that can be used to
transfer small volumes of bulk liquid
and so one thing that i envision
happening is if we want to really
increase throughput
while dealing with staff limitations is
to use a platform
uh like the beckman access system uh
they can handle
uh preparing your master mixes and
dispensing these into
many 380 fold plates these could be your
arctic
pcr amplicons one or two or your
indexing pcr
or your rt plate and then you can have
samples
in either 384 well echo
plates or on your to base liquid
handling to transfer them
in uh but this system could on the fly
create
your uh your mixes for you um and so
again
all of our amplifications are using a
standard pcr mix and
we just have a different type of primer
mix in there and so those could be local
located in acoustic source wells and
source plates um that are automatically
fed into the liquid handler
to create whatever plates you need kind
of on demand and also be able to handle
you know many many plates at a time
instead of the one or two three
different wool plates that we're running
in our current batches and so this has
the ability to really really increase
throughput
um to that next scale so we're
interested in playing around with
with ideas like this and so um with that
i'd like to acknowledge um a lot of the
zap that that did the work
um this was done um in the ucsf center
for advanced technology um and delta
martinez and tyler miyazaki
uh were really instrumental in in doing
the work and getting this done
i'd like to thank joe darici in his lab
they provided the initial 384 samples
that we compared as well as the data
using the standard arctic method
um amy kissler from cdc biohub for uh
great conversations
i'd like to really thank the idc team
from the chan zuckerberg
initiative that developed a um
essentially a cloud-based method that's
uh free for anybody to use to do sars
kobe 2
um genome analysis and so this is how
we've been uh calculating our our
coverage and they've been great
in terms of uploading our protocol our
specific protocol
um into their uh analysis platform and
lastly i'd also like to thank all the
members of the arctic network but you
know the work that we're doing here
uh with this method is really based on
all the groundwork uh that they've been
doing
again not just for star skill v2 but
even before stars kobe 2
uh with things like zika and dengue and
so they provided a really great
framework
uh to do a lot of this this
high-throughput sequencing
uh that most people around the world are
now using for for source code v2
uh and with that um thank you for
listening i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you eric for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
you mentioned improved throughput using
this method
in what way did echo help you with
improving your throughput
yeah that's a great question so um i'd
say there are a couple areas where
the uh echo acoustic liquid standard
really helped with uh
with throughput um you know first of all
again i mentioned i think a couple times
that it really
decreases tiff usage which can uh you
know be a limiting factor right now for
um i know a lot of groups are running
into chip shortages which is preventing
work
and without tips you've got no
throughput at all
and so by leveraging the the echo we've
actually been able to
cut down our tip usage per sample to
just two tips
for each and by decreasing the amount of
tips that we need
we haven't run into any supply
constraints the second area that it
really helps with
throughput is i'd say in the the pooling
steps so
at some point we need to pull all 3d
four ball samples together
um and so that can either use up a lot
of tips as well as take up a lot of time
if you're using the traditional to face
liquid handler but with the the echo
that pulling only takes about two
minutes
uh and so this has really helped as well
and
we also feel like the echo by the nature
of how it does the
the liquid transfers where the source
and destination plates
are really close together you really
minimize the
chance of contamination and often if you
have uh you know contamination your
controls uh what we and most other
groups will do
is have to repeat uh the run and so by
minimizing contamination you minimize
the number of reruns that you have to do
which also greatly increases throughput
the last thing we haven't done
yet that we're looking to do is how to
decrease our volumes
our current reaction volumes are
currently 10 microliters and that's kind
of a nice place to work with
with tip-based liquid handlers but
against reducing the echo we think
there's a possibility of decreasing that
by several fold
and that's probably next on our list to
to help increase
our our throughput
thank you eric our next question
how much volume can you hold in a
destination plate upside down when
pooling
and what type of plate are you using as
the destination plate
yeah so um for um the work that we do
um we're using buy rad 96 or 3d for well
plates for our our destination plates
and really with the echo you can use
pretty much any type of sbs format plate
that you um you want to work with
as long as i think they're below like 14
millimeters in in height that's the
the only limitation but you know pretty
much any
fully started pcr flight is is going to
work and we go up to 15 microliters
in volume for the destination plate uh
just so we don't fill it up too much
and um we just want to make sure that
you don't fill it up so much that you
get
you know dripping at the end so with 15
microliters uh
is a very safe volume that we haven't
seen any you know drips or anything like
that happening with the system
thank you eric our next question
after the pandemic how do you see using
this workflow to sequence other
pathogens
yeah so um yeah there's something we've
been thinking about
uh as well so the cat's done a lot of
kind of metagenomic sequencing in the
past we'll try to look for for other
pathogens and
um star scale ob2 was our first
experience
uh with this arctic network protocol and
method
and something we realize is that what's
great about this method is that it's
really a framework you know you can use
essentially the same procedures for any
pathogen you just design
a new set of multiplex primers your
reaction mixes are all identical
um you know for all the different steps
right whether it's an rt reaction
a multiplex vcr reaction or an indexing
pcr reaction so the only difference is
your samples
and then your primer sets and so once
you've designed your primer sets
within the same run again leveraging the
kind of
random access nature of the the echo you
could use the echo
to process many different types of
samples on a single plate because you
use the echo
to spot out your uh your multiplex pcr
mix
um into the the wells that you need for
your particular pathogen
and again for those who haven't worked
with an echo or
a uh a liquid handler with like a spande
multi-channel head that can do cherry
picking
what you do is you just feed a
spreadsheet that just instructs the
system what type of sample
this and what well and that'll tell the
system which primer set to deposit into
that well
and so we think that could be you know
one way of setting this up
especially if you have a higher
throughput you know access system where
you can load multiple plates
in hotels at once place contain your
your samples your destination rt plates
or pcr plates
as well as source plates containing your
indexing primers and your multiplex pcr
primers for different pathogens
all right thank you eric our next
question
you mentioned you only use two tips how
many in total
if you also count the extraction part
yeah that's a good question so that's
going to depend on your method of of
extraction
and so again this protocol that i'm
describing using two tips
is only starting from uh purified rna
so we haven't tried doing any type of uh
direct amplification from
say like saliva or heat inactivated
extracts
um but i've seen different protocols for
rna extraction
ranging from as many as you know 14 15
tips
uh all the way down to two tips uh
depending on the uh the protocol that
you were you're using
but you know what we think would be a
workflow would be most groups would do
dpcr testing that would require rna
traction anyways and you have rna left
over
and after you get your positive hits
determined by qpcr you can go back to
those source plates and pull out the
purified rna
and then go into your your sequencing
workflow
all right thank you eric our next
question can you talk a little bit
of the liquid handler software how was
your experience programming the liquid
handlers
yeah so um you know one thing we really
like about the uh the beckman systems
is the kind of ease of use so the the
cad is actually an
open access technology facility we
typically don't do
a sample prep um but you know i think
the pandemic kind of
changed the roles we all play and so we
kind of jumped in to do
uh stars kobe 2 sequencing because of
the need but
traditionally in the cat all the
instruments that we have including
our liquid handlers are used by anybody
on campus and we provide training
and so for the tip-based liquid handlers
on the fx and the i-series
we typically just do a one-hour training
with users who want to learn to use the
platform
and that's enough to get them going to
start writing their own protocols so
it's relatively
straightforward because of the kind of
graphical user interface you don't have
to
know much or anything about scripting
for instance or programming
on the echoes even easier it's a little
less dangerous because you don't have to
worry about tip crash you just right
because you're not working with with
tips and then our training for that
ranges from 30 minutes to one hour
uh to get people started so it's um
pretty easy to
to get started on via the protocol uh
and
and start to program these instruments
which we we really like in the context
of a core facility with many users
all right thank you again eric next
question
what volume did you run your rt reaction
yeah so um all of our reaction volumes
were 10 microliters so these included
the
um the rt reaction um that was run in
the echo low dead volume plates
so we started out with two microliters
of the uh um
of the uh 5x uh this lunascript master
mix that we
we use and then we add eight microliters
of rna on top of that so that was used
in that first
biomec fx 96 well liquid handler to do
that that transfer
and then the subsequent multiplex pcrs
were 10 microliters as well as the
indexing pcr
and um again i think there's probably
definitely a lot of room to further
decrease those volumes if you want to
want to drop costs just because of the
ease of
lower volume transfers with the echo and
so that's something we're uh we're
playing around with as well
great thank you again eric we have time
for one more question
do you anticipate decrease of your
sequencing throughput as the pandemic
winds down in north america
yeah that would be the the hope right
that we can all give back to
uh to our normal lives but uh i would
say that even if uh you know case rates
go down
by a lot you know right now i don't even
know if in this country we're sequencing
five percent of of all the positives
so you know ideally you could you would
sequence as many of the positive cases
um
as you can so i'd say that you know
even if you were to decrease number of
positive cases by
uh another 20 fold we might be able to
sequence 100
of uh of all the samples so i'd say that
i don't think anytime
soon we'll be kind of decreasing the
need for for sequencing again i think
it's going to be important to also
continue sequencing um you know positive
cases
uh especially among vaccinated
individuals and to be honest you know we
we totally expect to see positive cases
among vaccinated
individuals just because you know the
the vaccines aren't 100
uh you know perfect so what we want to
do is just make sure that there isn't
some maybe nasty variant that
can escape the vaccine again there's no
uh variant that escapes the vaccine so
everyone should still go out and get
vaccinated but
i think the surveillance is going to be
important just to um detect
if if that does happen so i'd say that
you know we're going to continue
sequencing for
the time going forward and there's also
a need for doing a lot of sequencing
um outside of of north america as well
just around the world so you know
hopefully some of these methods
uh and platforms can become a use for
for people
outside of north america too
all right thanks again eric do you have
any final comments for our audience
before we go
uh no i just wanted to um you know thank
the audience for uh
tuning in today and listening and then
also just wanted to again
acknowledge um the people who worked on
on this project and also
again thank the uh the groups around uh
working around the at the arctic network
so there's a group of individuals who've
been working for for several years and
other pathogens and really shifted focus
on starch cov2
and have really built a lot of great
protocols and resources then and and
share them widely
um just to make it accessible to uh to
all groups i yeah i definitely want to
thank them for for all their hard work
as well
well thank you again dr eric ciao for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor beckmann culture life
sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye